les panneaux ne changeront pas mais pour
2023 la ville de Pantin s'appelle
pantine une décision prise par le maire
pour sensibiliser les habitants à
l'égalité femme homme certains y voit un
signe positif à condition que des actes
suivent c'est bien qui commence à avoir
que les femmes c'est aussi important que
les hommes c'est une belle initiative je
trouve ça sympa c'est très très juste
pas question de modifier les panneaux
les adresses également ne changent pas
un symbole qui n'est pas forcément au
goût de tous les habitants c'est pas
très intéressant pour soutenir la cause
les initiatives concrètes que nous avons
sur le terrain ne trouve pas d'écho
alors elles ont une réalité elles font
avancer les choses elles font avancer le
droit des femmes mais pour autant on en
parle pas et donc là avec ce petit e
j'ai voulu un peu provoquer la
discussion provoquer la prise de
conscience il fait sa publicité à bon
compte sur le dos de l'égalité
homme-femme mais dans le même temps
monsieur Kern a comme premier un homme
Tartuffe faux dévot monsieur Kern est le
maire de Pantin depuis 2001 mais il ne
lui viendrait pas l'idée de laisser sa
place l'espace d'une année à une femme
Tartuffe le but est de faire parler des
inégalités femmes et ça fonctionne on en
a parlé toute la matinée après alors
évidemment tout le monde a pensé à la
vanne il peut se permettre ça parce
qu'il est maire de Pantin hein tes
maires de Mâcon ah c'est quand même
beaucoup plus dur devant tes administrés
les tartuffes sont dans la ville ils
plastronent le cœur en bandoulière la
morale en étendard la fourberie en cache
poussière les tartuffes sont dans la
ville ils traversent les époques les
chatenites qui grimacent les pharisiens
qui godillent les imposteurs qui
pullulent Tartuffe le 3 le 7 le 8 le 7
[Musique]
guerre d'avis polémique et oui
la polémique en fait si je réagis si je
veux m'explique je lui donne je
l'aliment et surtout je lui donne de la
valeur ce que j'ai dit je l'ai dit c'est
écrit en français dans une interview qui
est disponible du coup le Parisien qui a
fait ce buzz en profit c'est donc sur le
Parisien que vous pouvez lire cette
interview chaque
Omar Sy lisez-la essayez de la
comprendre et si vous la comprenez pas
tant pis pour vous si vous ne savez pas
lire il y a encore des profs en France
après je suis flatté moi de de d'être un
sujet plus intéressant que la galette
des rois c'est vrai que c'est plus
intéressant de parler de moi de la
galette des rois donc du coup ils ont un
truc à se raconter qu'il le fasse mais
moi ça va pas m'empêcher de dire ce que
j'ai à dire au moment j'ai à le dire et
puis après l'interprétation les choses
sortis de ce contexte en tout cas je
rentrerai pas dans le jeu de devoir me
justifier raconter ou d'expliquer ce que
j'ai dit on est heureux de vous recevoir
à épanoui super contente d'être chez
vous non mais c'est vrai je vous regarde
très souvent et j'étais venu juste pour
manger à la base parce que
parce que j'avais très faim vous savez
j'habite à Dubaï c'est très loin non je
suis vraiment très contente d'être avec
vous ce soir alors le vrai bonheur ne
dépend d'aucun être d'aucun objet
extérieur il ne dépend que de vous
d'ailleurs la main qui ça va
[Rires]
au Pérou la loi donne à peu près toutes
les libertés aux parents au moment de
choisir un prénom ils ont donc tendance
à prénommer leur enfant bah selon leur
star préférée Emmanuel a très très peur
en 2022 on a eu 700 bébés péruviens qui
ont été prénommés Pelé ou Rai Pelé en
hommage évidemment au roi Pelé
ça passe
500 petites péruviennes ont été
baptisées reine Élisabeth ou Elisabeth
II c'est là je je j'arrive pas à croire
que je vous vois là je suis là je suis
vrai
c'est comme si je vois la Joconde
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour vous et je
vous trouve magnifique c'est gentil
des parents péruviens c'est de loin
Cristiano Ronaldo 31000 bébés prénommés
Cristiano Ronaldo cette année très loin
devant les 371 petits Messi et 2029
Kylian Mbappe mon composé voilà qu'il y
a de Mbappé pour des petits péruviens et
de l'alcool est bon allié l'amour il
faut payer qui est un peu le résumé de
la vie de famille est-ce que vous
bloquez ces paroles est-ce que vous avez
avec quel argent vu que tu nous payes
arrête de boire déjà
pour oublier là Ronaldo Mania à son
apogée hier en Arabie Saoudite c'était
totalement grandiose Cristiano Ronaldo
très attendu dans son nouveau club
d'elnasser a été acclamé par un stade de
33000 supporters Valentin Germain le
footballeur a été accueilli comme une
véritable Rockstar oui dans une ambiance
incandescente Cristiano Ronaldo maillot
jaune et bleu sur les épaules sort du
couloir pénètre sur le terrain
23000 euros par heure pour Cristiano
Ronaldo qui a rejoint le club
dallelasser en Arabie Saoudite jusqu'en
2025 vous qui voulez un petit peu
d'argent vous faites pas du foot là-bas
[Applaudissements]
16 millions d'euros par mois des jeux de
lumière anime le stade les flammes
jaillissent de la pelouse les supporters
sortent des fumigènes et l'attaquant
souris
c'est un plaisir d'être ici j'ai senti
l'accueil magnifique que l'on m'a
réservé et bien sûr je vais donner le
meilleur Ford
[Applaudissements]
555000 euros par jour et en plus ils ont
rajouté dans son contrat 5 voitures
un palais dans la ville de Riyad qui
inclut une compagnie de sécurité
complète un magasin privé un super
marché une piscine olympique deux
terrains de foot un terrain de basket de
gymnase trois restaurants
le Portugais est aussi interrogé sur son
contrat record à 200 millions d'euros
par an pour être honnête je m'en fiche
de ce que les gens disent ce contrat est
unique car je suis un joueur unique
donc j'ai pas lu espèce de zinzin
à tout de suite